[Musica]
bene
oggi
[Musica]
ehi ma affida in africa africa
africa e affigga amica
[Musica]
marika in africa
in africa
ecco
[Musica]
si no
no
[Musica]
dopo
giu
[Musica]
ok
no
c'era io
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quattromila chilometri da qui
nell'arcipelago norvegese delle isole
svalbard è stata costruita nella roccia
dentro una montagna una cassaforte in
questa cassaforte sono custoditi i semi
della cultura più importanti della terra
si tratta del deposito globale dei semi
delle isole svalbard
a poco meno di 600 chilometri da qui da
parma nel nord della puglia nella
capitanata
esistono invece due tra i più grandi
ghetti d'italia il ghetto di rignano
garganico e il ghetto di borgo mezzanone
la pista si tratta di due grandi
baraccopoli in cui le persone vivono in
condizioni indegne si vive in delle case
di cartone di legno di lamiera non si ha
accesso all'energia elettrica all'acqua
potabile ai servizi igienici in questi
luoghi vivono circa tremila persone
molte di queste sono proprio quei
lavoratori che raccolgono il cibo che
troviamo nei supermercati
o sulle nostre tavole nei nostri
frigoriferi due istantanee da una parte
i semi la nostra biodiversità
rinchiusa in un caveau per essere
protetta dall'altra parte migliaia di
lavoratori in chiusi in delle
baraccopoli affinché rimangano
invisibili tra queste due
istantanee tra questi due punti nel
nostro emisfero
in questo spazio
ci sono i grandi temi della nostra
contemporaneità i cambiamenti climatici
il modo in cui consumiamo e produciamo
il cibo il consumo dell'acqua
il tema del lavoro il tema delle
migrazioni
ma che cosa lega poi effettivamente
quello questa realtà delle baracche del
sud italia e quanto troviamo sul nostro
tavolo
pensiamo alla nostra quotidianità
torniamo a casa la sera e vogliamo
preparare un pasto per degli amici
nella cassetta della posta troviamo
decine di volantini promozionali
15 riunisce una bottiglia di passata di
pomodoro a 39 centesimi e un pacco di
pasta 60 centesimi è quel che ci serve
andiamo al discount ma com'è possibile
che io possa preparare un pasto per 4
persone
spendendo quanto per un caffè
questo succede perché spesso dietro
queste offerte imperdibili dietro il
sottocosto
c'è una pratica commerciale che sembra
più un gioco d'azzardo
si tratta delle aste a doppio ribasso
il funzionamento è semplice una grande
catena di supermercati
deve rifornirsi di una certa partita di
merce e indice una sta
fissando un prezzo di partenza i
fornitori rispondono con un'offerta
vince l'offerta più bassa non la più
alta
verrà quindi indetta una seconda sta a
partire dal prezzo più basso che
determinerà il fornitore finale
come ben capite questo tipo di
meccanismo
massimizza il profitto ma schiaccia
tutta la filiera e questo stesso
meccanismo è stato utilizzato durante
una delle più grandi crisi che ha
riguardato e riguarda tutti noi la crisi
pandemica
nel marzo del 2020 una notissima catena
di supermercati acquistava un enorme
partita di
insalate in busta attraverso un'asta
doppio ribasso
200mila pezzi di insalate in busta
acquistate per circa 30 centesimi il 30
per cento in meno
il prezzo di partenza
da anni insieme a terra ci interroghiamo
sul funzionamento delle figlie e
produttive in campo agricolo e lo
facciamo attraverso inchieste attraverso
rapporti di ricerca attraverso campagne
di sensibilizzazione
ed è proprio grazie alla campagna durate
cinque anni nei confronti dei cittadini
dei consumatori e dei decisori politici
che finalmente da qualche giorno abbiamo
una legge una legge che vieta le aste a
doppio ribasso ora però è tempo di
dedicarsi in maniera più forte più
incisiva per tutelare i milioni di
lavoratori italiani e stranieri che sono
schiacciati dal lavoro nero sono
schiacciati dal lavoro grigio e da
dinamiche di povertà
abbiamo una legge contro il caporalato
una legge importante ma non è
sufficiente
con questa orchestra l'orchestra di
braccianti vogliamo raccontare quello
che succede nelle campagne vogliamo
raccontarlo in coinvolgendo i
protagonisti coloro che i ghetti li
hanno conosciuti molto bene un'orchestra
quindi che ha un motore di integrazione
è uno strumento di lavoro è uno
strumento di denuncia
un'orchestra che in qualche modo tutela
anche una biodiversità sonora che si
dice non la musica è un linguaggio
universale in realtà la musica è un
insieme di tante lingue con codici e
sonorità diverse ed è proprio quella
biodiversità
che in norvegia hanno dovuto rinchiudere
una cassaforte per proteggerla dalla
nostra stupidità della nostra avidità
il primo brano che avete sentito
si intitola africa è stato scritto da
joshua e arrangiato dal direttore
artistico dell'orchestra federico
pascucci e vi lasceremo con un ultimo
brano freedom un inno alla libertà che
speriamo arrivi scritto da adam per
l'orchestra è sempre arrangiato da
federico pascucci
e lo dedichiamo a buy e un altro
componente dell'orchestra che oggi non
può essere con noi perché non tutti
hanno la fortuna di avere un passaporto
europeo
grazie
[Musica]
ad oggetto di colpi giusti
poche foto sempre
[Musica]
attentissimi a torce stele in ricordo
si no
donne
tutto
ad un gesto e le 20
stato gestito in difficoltà
ad un gesto ii e di corsa
all avanti
tutto
[Musica]
è di pochi
a dodici stelle e di colpa ad oggi
[Musica]
niente
ma dite
giovani grazie ciao ciao con la serata
tutti
bene
[Applauso]
[Musica]